you need to embrace your challenges
artists talk about walking straight
towards things that most of us would run
away from Chuck Close was severely
learning disables as a kid and he had
such trouble at school that his eighth
grade teacher said to him Chuck don't
even think about college you should go
the vocational route you're not going to
make it and this is a guy who went on to
get his MFA from Yale and become a
world-renowned artist he has something
called face blindness where he can't
recognize faces in three dimensions all
of his work is portraits he takes
photographs and then makes his painting
from those photographs also he has a
tremendous difficulty understanding the
whole really getting the the big picture
and so what he does with his paintings
as he breaks them down into grids and he
paints little piece by little piece
until as he says he builds a painting he
doesn't paint the painting Chuck Close
really rose to fame on his big
self-portrait a wonderful picture that
looks like it's seamless he actually did
it on a grid but then he erased all the
grid marks so that the picture looked
almost like a photograph later in his
career he started to let the grid show
this is the way he figured out how to
paint because he couldn't grasp the
whole he would take a photograph but
then what he needed to do in order to
paint it was break it down into little
pieces if you get up really close it
just looks like a bunch of dots with a
grid over top of it but as you pull back
suddenly it turns into a face and you
see that this is a person what's
extraordinary about Chuck Close is he
grappled with his learning disabilities
himself he really didn't have anybody to
say here's the interventions that you
need Chuck for being able to grasp the
whole he worked it out through his art
and was able to through his painting
help understand how he understands the
world and helped organize it for himself
you